all right today can you believe it 22
years after the September 11th attacks
and I kept thinking to myself
what if something like that happened to
our country with Joe Biden in charge
in moments of Crisis our presidents are
supposed to reassure a worried Nation
this nation stands with the good people
of New York City
and New Jersey and Connecticut
as we mourn the loss of thousands of our
citizens
[Music]
I can hear you
[Applause]
I can hear you the rest of the world
hears you and the people
and the people who knocked these
buildings down will hear all of us soon
[Applause]
could Biden today ever pull off such an
emotional unscripted moment
well let's see how we did over the
weekend during a non-crisis
and uh I see
I'm just following my orders here
uh
staff is there anybody having spoken
no I ain't calling on you I'm calling I
said they had five questions
this trip was cringe-worthy from
beginning to end and remember that's
some of the same left-wing trolls who've
been covering for Biden senility had no
problem trashing Bush for appearing what
they saw thought was unserious when he
continued to read that book to the
second graders after being told about
the World Trade Center attacks
not knowing what to do
with no one telling him what to do and
no secret service rushing in to take him
to safety Mr Bush just sat there
and continued to Read My Pet Goat with
the children
seems even more Petty more off base and
more vindictive than it did 20 years ago
especially given who's leading us now
in the world in five days is interesting
one of my staff members said Remember
the famous song You Know Good morning
Vietnam well good evening Vietnam but I
tell you what I don't know about you but
I'm going to go to bed
the weekend was so bad that the Press
could no longer avoid reporting on
Biden's weak performance
notion of Joe Biden The Experience Joe
Biden the reality of his age there is
significant concern and pulls from
Americans about the president's age
there are times where you do see some
verbal missteps Joe Biden's biggest
weakness is his age
no it's bigger than that but that's a
start but now we've noted a new shift in
framing courtesy of New York Times
columnist Frank Rooney now check out the
title here to his column Trump is really
old too
what now they may be only what four
years or so apart in age but does anyone
doubt that Trump actually makes his own
policy decisions on the border on
foreign policy on trade on economic
policy no one doubts he makes his own
decisions after getting a lot of inputs
and his policies they work well to keep
us safe and keep us prosperous so look
you might dislike his tone you might
disagree with how we handle things
post-election night but you cannot tell
me that America wasn't better off in
2019 than we are today under the
bumbling Biden
and no serious person alive thinks that
Biden is deciding anything important and
no serious person alive thinks that
Biden is capable of anything beyond the
occasional reading of prepared remarks
and the frightening thing about all of
this is that world leaders also know
that if they want to raise an important
issue about what we're doing where Biden
is not the person to raise it with
because if you raise it with Biden
you're likely to get stuck hearing one
of his old stories
and there's a my my brother loves Heaven
there's famous lines from movies that he
always quotes you know is and what one
of them is there's there's a movie about
John Wayne he's an Indian Scout and
they're trying to get the I think
there's a patch of one of the
great tribes of America back on the
reservation and he's standing with the
Union so he's roll on their in their on
their horses and their Saddles and
there's three or four Indians and
headdresses and the Union Soldiers the
union Soul was basically saying it is
come with me we'll take care of you
we'll be everything will be good and the
Indian Scout the Indian looks at John
Wayne and points to the union so says
he's a lion dog face pony soldier
well there's a lot of lying dog face
Pony soldiers out there about about
global warming but not anymore
on my word I can't count the times that
Biden has been told that he has the
movie in the phrase wrong it's basically
a mishmash from the John Wayne movie and
a Tyrone Powers flick come on man
but the Press well they just let him
ramble on
so we know that this guy who can't get a
movie reference right didn't green light
that series of summertime trips that all
the Biden cabinet officials made to
China now recall Carrie blinken Yellen
and Gina raimondo all went to suck up to
president XI
all got cold water thrown in their faces
but whoever's in charge of our China
policy whether it's Goldman Sachs some
hedge fund guys talking to Tony blinken
we don't know but voters should know
that who decided it was a good idea
after everyone uh for Biden to everyone
going there and getting nothing for
Biden to go grovel to XI in Vietnam
who signed off on the surrender language
that they put in Biden script
what this trip was about it was less
about containing China I I don't want to
contain China I just want to make sure
we have a relationship with China that
is on the up and up squared away I want
to see China succeed economically but I
want to see him succeed by the rules
of course when we have a figurehead
president voters are going to be kept in
the dark
as America continues to see the boot
licking buffoonery of this White House
Tony blinken's spending so much time in
Beijing he I think he should just have
his mail forwarded there at this point
if at least for the rest of the time
that Biden's in office he's going back
to Beijing later this year
so voters May believe that the current
Dynamic this White House is functioning
as a nursing home it's going to begin
and end with Biden right well that would
be an incorrect assumption
remember the establishment and certainly
the big donors who are desperate to do
business with China they're perfectly
content to have what's tantamount to
kind of a hologram president who does
what he or she is told
so the angle expects that if heaven
forbid Kamala Harris were ever to become
president
should be just as much of a figurehead
as Biden
after all if the question is who is less
capable of carrying out the duties of
the presidency Joe or Kamala I'm pretty
sure it would be a tie
consider her bad acting job in
yesterday's Face the Nation interview
are you prepared to be
commander-in-chief yes I am if necessary
but Joe Biden is going to be fine and
let me tell you something
I work with Joe Biden every day under
Joe Biden's leadership we have
transformed and are in the process of
transforming America's infrastructure
wait she works with Joe Biden every day
doing what exactly crossword puzzles the
jumble practicing how to climb the
stairs
and when legitimate questions are raised
about whether Harris's abilities or
Biden's Fitness for office about all of
that even the most devoted apparat
chicks are scrambling at this point to
try to reassure people
why is Kamala so dangerous that's kind
of offensive to me and the other thing
is she's unprepared the woman is ready
to lead if she need if she needs to lead
but I don't think Joe Biden's going
anywhere because I see him on his bike
in Delaware I can't bike that much and I
mean he's he's he's fit
but sunny it's looking cloudy
according to a new CBS you gov poll a
significant segment of democrat voters
are both angrier and less enthusiastic
with Harris on the ticket
so Americans are going to have a stark
choice to make next year vote for a
republican who is actually capable of
making important decisions capable of
dealing with serious challenges we're
facing in China capable of speaking
clearly in a time of crisis
or vote for the status quo
a man who decides nothing does what he's
told and gives our enemies constant
openings to do us great harm
it should be an easy choice
and that's the angle hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else